I am 35,000 feet above the North
Atlantic somewhere to South Bend
and there's no great art of winter here
because nope
for sharing this aspects
so
like how do
the answer it's down at my destination
continued for 205 miles this is the NAV
CANADA area control center in gander
Newfoundland and if you're over the
North Atlantic these are some of the
folks keeping you safe the North
Atlantic tracks are the Airways that we
develop each day for our eastbound
aircraft to fly across from from us over
to the UK area the westbam tracks are
produced by our counterpart over in
Scotland by a preswick center the way
the North Atlantic works there's
basically two main air flows during the
night time our our nighttime here most
of the aircraft will leave North America
and fly across to the UK and during the
daytime we'll Sudheer those same
aircraft returned it's a 24-hour
operation obviously we start with our
day shift comes in early in the morning
we'll ask all these aircraft to send in
their preferred routes for that night so
I'll take that in consideration I'll
also look at weather models eastbound
aircraft the all the aircraft want to
get into the main jet stream to pick up
that tailwind so they can save money and
fuel on time and from all that will
develop a set of tracks you know based
on that flow and once the tracks are
published in the morning Airlines then
have anywhere from 8 to 10 and 12 hours
to decide a what track they want to
follow that night the trucks can look
curved and inefficient on the flat map
projections were used to but you've got
to remember they're great circle routes
but the shortest and cheapest way around
the globe of the earth and also the
tracks are three dimensional planes can
be separated because they're on a
different track or because they're on a
different position on the same track or
by altitude it's a requirement for an
aircraft to give us a position report
every 10 degrees allowing - and we take
that information we apply it to the
aircraft's route and we update our
system and we can kind of predict where
he's gonna be - when there's no radar
coverage there's two main forms of
communicating the aircraft on Atlantic
Ocean you can go through our radio
operators or flight service operators
and contact them through HF but the
easiest way for us I guess it's like a
form of text mining to a polyp I can
just click on a button and I can tell
exactly where that aircraft is - at that
point in time it's very precise even
without radar as a normal standard for
track side by side which is our lateral
separation we're running 60 nautical
miles per as time progresses airlines
get better equipped we'll probably have
all our tracks at 30 miles apart from
each other the longitudinal which is one
aircraft behind the other we're running
10 minutes we can reduce that down to a
five minutes standard if airline are
equipped on a vertical were using a
thousand feet someplace you can just sit
it on your pad you want a nice clear day
you can see numerous aircraft and he
look like draw on top of each other but
basically they're all at least a
thousand feet apart if not more it's
just had to be separate into one
dimension basically as soon as an
aircraft gets too tight to another
aircraft then we intersect and say okay
we need to slow you down or speed you up
traffic permitting obviously I mean if
plane has an emergency they have
contingency procedures they have dirty
cast he passes their traffic collision
avoidance system for instance if you had
two aircraft on an aircraft did
something wasn't supposed to do climbed
up into another aircraft at that plane
as a Tcat system that says okay you have
any incoming traffic you have to you
know climb really saying or whatever the
resolution is I mean so as soon as we're
made aware of an urgency situation we
look at separation we try to move what
aircraft we can we provide a
conflict-free
clearance for that aircraft safety being
the number one thing thank you very much
to everyone at Nav Canada and at the
gander area control center you can find
out more about them and the tracks of
the links in the description